Jaakko I struggle with receiving banter
from other guys banter okay I'm
naturally a sensitive guy which lends
myself to take normal smack talk from
other guys personally I'm trying to get
after it I wake up early I work out eat
healthy work pretty hard but still seem
to have some deep-seated insecurities
which flare up when guys give me stick I
have some bloody good mates and I want
to get to the point where I can take
smack talk for what it is and even give
a bit of stick back to the guys what can
I do to help this here's one thing that
you can try to get into your brain and
this is one of those things that's hard
to get into your brain and it's even
harder to actually get it your brain and
functionally use this thought here's the
thought the more okay if you're if
you're paranoid about something if
you're insecure about something the more
you let things bother you the more
insecure you will appear hmm but let me
say it again
the more you let things bother you the
more insecure you're going to appear and
the worse whatever that thing that
you're worried about whatever that thing
that makes you feel insecure the worse
it's going to appear to everyone else so
if you got a big nose and you're
embarrassed because you've got a big
nose and every time someone says
something about your big nose you get
mad and you get offended that big nose
it glows even bigger so think about that
if there's something that bothers you
and you let it be known and you let it
bother you divorce it's gonna get and
and also think about this another thing
that will help these are things I'm
trying to help help sort of smooth the
edges of insecurity here's another one
people even though you think you really
think they are and it's kind of
egotistical to think this but we all do
it people aren't sitting around and
thinking about you and your weaknesses
yeah
they're not sitting around and thinking
about you and your weaknesses they're
not like that's your ego telling you
that so don't sit there and think
everyone's looking at your big nose all
the time they don't care they got their
other problems they got their own life
going on they don't care about your big
nose you know what makes them care about
it when they know if they say something
you it bothers you oh yeah that's the
first thing you're gonna think when they
see you again oh here comes a good time
for some fun and here's another thing if
you want to kind of mitigate that man
they do it do it
mark doesn't weigh the warrior kid when
Uncle Jake says hey if you're getting
made fun of he's in way the word kid
called plate face yeah
say mark oh you got around this guy
Nathan James is telling mark oh you got
a round face you look like a plate calls
him plate face that's his insult as he
insults him all the time and it bothers
him he's looking in the mirror go away
lets it bother him and Uncle Jake says
hey go go make fun of yourself and he
finally gets a chance he does a there
you know a class and they have to do a
self portrait and he draws himself as a
plate a plate face and when the kid
that's been making fun of it season he
laughs and then guess what doesn't make
fun of him anymore about it because he
realizes it doesn't bother and they kind
of bond a little bit they kind of moms
actually what he's going for
in this question that is yeah yeah so
you got him any see it's this is what
that's why I said it's hard to do this
because when you're insecure about your
big nose or you're insecure about your
big ears or whatever and you let people
know that or you just think it's in your
brain you think if you say something
that's gonna be remorse it won't get
worse yeah might get worse for uptick
for a second right it might you make fun
of yourself you know people
oh yeah that's right you notice that you
do it yeah then it'll kind of no one
really cares and that's why in the teams
in the teams you never let anyone know
that something bothers you or if they
know it bothers you you're gonna hear
about it forever that's just gonna be
how this is the way it's gonna be and
what that means the polar opposite of
that or the flip side of that is it's
not fun to harass some it's not fun to
harass someone about something that
doesn't bother them it's not even fun
right it's not fun why would you harass
someone when they don't get it you don't
even get a rise out of him yeah it's not
fun you just leave that thing you look
for something else yeah so poke a little
fun at yourself
these guys are gonna back off because
they're bored if you show no reaction
and like you said that that kind of
self-deprecating humor will form a
little bond yeah you can give a little
stick back to the guys if you start
giving stick to guys be ready to take it
back though yes and they're gonna
escalate yeah and the that's just uh I
mean I grew up with two brothers mm-hmm
one twin brother and that's like like
that's literally the foundation of our
relationship it's just you tease the
other guy about some let everything like
you he can come in with a new shirt on
that's a seal platoon
yeah like it'll be like oh sure you know
like that's not even something to you
someone they sell men's shirts where you
bought that yeah yeah whatever
it's Lear that's it's so bad to the
point where one um when when I got with
my current wife Fullmer when we started
dating or whatever like it's just habit
you know like even you like same thing
you know like you'll you'll give me crap
I'll give you him whatever but it's so
common that I do it to hurt you oh yeah
yeah and you know at first she's like Oh
what like what why are you teasing me so
much like you're because I know even
before we were together
I knew her for gears actually and he's
like I kind of knowing you know he's
like teases or whatever and I had it's
like reel it back yourself in check yeah
because that because that is so so much
of how guys do yeah you know hundred
percent okay and I've told this story
before when I got when I was going to
college and what's around team guys all
day and I started doing the team guy
thing with my wife she's like hey I'm
not in the teams so you can be quiet now
and I was like wow she's right and I'd
even realize it cuz that's just you know
all day long you show up at a you show
up in the platoon space and it's verbal
sparring yes as soon as you walk through
the door somebody's gonna say something
they're gonna bring it and what's
interesting is Holly's how do you think
I want to get to the point where you
know he can Spector with thing is I
would agree with this probably even 110
percent which is hard to agree hundred
percent but I feel this way it's
probably stronger than him like you ever
been around someone who like you just
can't really joke around with like I'm
not I who I'll tease someone and try to
like to make them you know specially I
don't know I'm good or whatever but um
the but if you're around someone who
like can't really take it you can't joke
around with them it's like men want that
guy to be their man I wish he just
wasn't you know I'm not mad at all but I
just I don't hang around with that guy
you don't want to be that guy no so even
if like it's fish at first like let's
say okay I'm this guy right here the
worst is someone that can dish it out
but can't take it yeah but yeah that is
the worst it's I don't I would the only
reason I wouldn't say he's the worth is
what if he's dishing it out and he can't
take it it's kind of you get a payoff of
teasing the guy I'm saying true it let's
say he doesn't dish it out let's say
it's just a guy you just can't joke
around with this like man you're making
me uncomfortable kind of thing you know
but if this guy cuz you what's your
point if it's yeah if float is annoying
when people can't take it and you make a
joke and they get all fired up and then
they're like actually mad right yeah
that's that is that's well that's how
you end up with people that aren't
really your friends oh yes exactly right
so but yes yes so you get there man hey
I say get there in at first just and you
kind of made it really clear to me how
you know when you make a change or
something it's not gonna bone your
arteries with the change going
full-speed you know what do you say blow
drag it's not gonna be like their reddit
for especially with this kind of stuff
if you if you already know you're
insecure yeah which is a big step ahead
by the way some people don't know
insecure and meanwhile they're he's
admitting it they know it but they just
don't admit it
yeah so just got you know so but you're
gonna feel it man when they call you bit
you know whatever they're calling you
whatever you're gonna sort of feel it on
the inside still but just don't behave
you know in a way just like god I don't
know I don't know what to do this plenty
of things to do but yeah I mean you do
want to get there 100% yeah jack